so we're on problem 76 which of the
following ratios is most nearly equal to
the ratio of 1 plus the square root of 5
to 2 and then they give us a bunch of
integer choices so this is really just a
problem of approximating what the square
root of 5 is so let's think about this a
little bit so this 2 is equal to the
square root of 4 writer 2 squared is
equal to 4 3 is equal to the square root
of 9 so the square root of 5 is going to
be a lot closer to 2 I mean even if we
said let's see what's what's two point
one squared two point one times two
point one you get 21 0 2 times 21 is 42
so then you get four for one so two
point one is equal to square root of
four point four one two point two let's
see two point two times two point two 2
is 44 0 44 this gets pretty close to
five eight four so two point two is I
think about as close as we're going to
get right so if we said 1 plus if we
approximately square root of 5 is two
point two and this is just an
approximation we just have to figure out
which choice is closest one plus two
point two over 2 that's equal to 3 point
2 over 2 and that's not one of the
choices because this really isn't an
integer choice but let's see if I can
just express this this is equal to C
this is equal to one point six right
give you one point six to one so we just
have to find which of the choices are
roughly equal to one point six to one so
choice a choice a 8 to 5 8 to 5 well
what is that that's 1 and 3/5 well
that's exactly 1 point 6 so that's the
choice I'm going to go with let me look
at the other ones yeah 6 to 5 is going
to be a lot closer to 1 5 2 4 6 2 5 is 1
point 2
five to four is 1.25 2 to 1 is 2 yeah so
choice a is the best choice
next question problem 77 77 let me
scroll down a little bit 7 over 1/5 plus
5 over 1 7 is equal to 7 divided by 1/5
is equal to 7 times 5 Plus 5 divided by
1/7 is equal to 5 times 7 right you when
you divide by a fraction is the same
thing as multiplying by its reciprocal
so 5 times 7 so this is equal to 35 plus
35 which is equal to 70 and that's
choice D 78 from January 1 1991 to
January 1 1993 the number of people
enrolled in health maintenance
organizations increased by 15% from 91
to 93 you increased by 15%
the enrollment on January 1 1993 was 45
million 45 million how many million
people to the nearest million were
enrolled in health maintenance
organizations on January 1 1991 ok so
let's just call this X right that's what
were they want to know they want to know
how many million people were enrolled in
1991 so when X increased by 15%
you got to 45 million right so remember
not 15% of X is 45 million x increases
by 15% so let me I'll write an extra
step that I normally don't do so you
could kind of view it as X plus 15% X
right that's an int this is X and then
you're increasing it by 15% of X is
going to be equal to 45 million and then
this is why this is 1 X plus 0.15 X so
that's 1.15 X is equal to 45 million and
you can often just go straight to this
step in fact you usually can what you
get used to it you could say Oh 15%
increase that's the same thing as
multiplying by one point one five so X
is equal to 45
/ 1.15 and we're going to have to do a
little bit of division to figure this
out 1 1 5 divided by 45 add a couple of
zeros so it was one point one five
divided by 45 so that's the same thing
is 115 take the decimal plates go to the
right going to 4500 right 115
goes into 450 how many times is it going
into it four times no that would be 460
so it goes into three times three times
115 is 345 345 this difference is 105
bring down a zero bring down a zero 115
goes into a thousand 50 how many times
let's see if I did eight eight hundred
eight I think it's eight times because
99 would be nine would be 200 actually
nine hundred plus 90 plus forty five
actually it would be nine times nine 9
times 5 is 45 9 times 1 is 9 plus 4 is
13 9 times 9 is 1 I'm side is 9 plus 1
is 10 you have a remainder 15 bring down
the 0 that goes one time so we already
have the decimal point and all their
choices are an integer so this is
closest to be 39 and I wanted to just
get that last decimal point because
maybe that was thirty nine point nine in
which case 40 would be the closest
choice sometimes they get tricky like
that next question 79 are is the set of
positive odd integers less than 50 R is
equal to positive odd less than 50 and
the integers integers
and S & S is equal to squares of our
squares of the numbers in that set how
many elements does the intersection of R
and s contain okay so we're essentially
have to go we have to say okay positive
odd integers less than 50 so we have to
think how many positive odd integers
less than 50 our squares of other
positive odd integers less than 50 right
so you can actually it doesn't take a
long time to figure out all of the
squares between 1 and 50 all right it's
1 2 4 9 16 25 they start increasing
pretty fast 36 36 49 okay now we know
that they have to be positive these are
all positive we know they have to be odd
right because we're looking for things
that are both squares and they're in set
R right their squares and their squares
of other things in set R so let's take
out all the even numbers can't be 36
can't be 2 can't be 4 can't be 16 and
let's see so 9 1 is 1 squared so 1 is in
set R it's a positive odd integer less
than 50 and it is a square of another
positive odd integer less than 50 a
square of itself so one counts 9 is 3
squared 9 itself is a positive odd
integer less than 50 and it's also the
square of 3 which is another positive
odd integer less than 50 so 9 counts 5
25 same logic it's a positive odd
integer less than 15 square 5 which is
the same and then 49 same thing square
of 7 both 49 and 7 are positive odd
integers less than 50 so I found 4 so
that's C question 80
question ad a retail appliance store
priced a video recorder 20% above the
wholesale cost of $200 so you could just
say we could just go okay 20% above 200
that's going to be 1.2 times 200 if a
store employee applied the 10% employee
discount to the retail price to buy the
recorder how much did the employee pay
for the recorder so this is what this is
the retail price right this was the
wholesale price that's what the store
bought it for this is what a non
employee would have to pay 1.2 times 200
and then the employee got a 10% discount
so essentially the employee paid the the
retail price times 0.9 we could get rid
of that times 0.9 all right so we just
have to figure out so what's 1.2 times
two hundred two hundred times 1.2 well
you could just multiply it let's just do
it out two times 200 is 400 add a zero
one times 200 is 200 and then we have
one point behind the desk a while this
addemup you get 2,400 we have one number
behind one digit behind the decimal so
it's 240 so the retail price is 240 and
then we have to multiply that times 0.9
to figure out what the employee pays
right they got a 10% discount which is
another way of saying they played 90
percent of the retail price
so 240 times nine point nine nine times
0 0 9 times 4 is 36 9 times 2 is 18 plus
3 21 we have one number behind the
decimal point so the employee paid two
hundred and sixteen dollars just choice
B now I'm out of time I'll continue this
in the next video